معي من مدينه نيكولايا بالاوكرانيه مراسل
العربيه حذيفه عادل حذيفه جديد المشهد من
ميكو لايف سواء على المستوى الميداني او
على المستوى الحياتي المعيشي تحديدا موضوع
على الكهرباء والطاقه والتدفئه
تحياتي طالب يعني في مدينه ميكلايف تحديدا
عاد التيار الكهربائي قبل حوالي نصف ساعه
فقط منذ الامس بعد الاستهداف الواسعه
النطاق ل 11 ولايه اوكرانيه بس 67 صاروقا
روسيا استهدف الفيديو تحتيه للطاقه وبعد
هذه الصواريخ سقطت في مناطق مهوله بالسكان
قتل نتيجه هذه الاستهلافات عدد من
المواطنين وجرح اخرون الان يتلقون الرعايه
الصحيه من بينهم هنا الان بينما نتحدث
وردت الاخبار من اخر الصور همم
قصف همم استمر او كان 13 مره تم قصف مدينه
اخر سلوى قتل شخص الان قبل قليل في قصف
اخير في مدينه خرسان الوضع طبعا صعب جدا
همم طالب في جميع المدن الاوكرانيه لذلك
الان السلطات الاوكرانيه تحاول ان تبتكر
الحلول ومن ضمن هذه الحلول هي همم عمليه
انشاء او تجهيز همم
بمولدات الكهرباء هي عباره عن خيام اا
توزع جغرافيه في المدن همم في كل مدينه تم
اا يعني حوالي في البدايه بدات بحوالي 40
ما بين ال 30 الى 40 مركز تم انشاءه اما
خيام او مناطق عباره عن همم مؤسسات لا
تعمل في الوقت الحالي تم تجهيزه بالمولدات
وكذلك بالتدفئه التي تعمل عن طريق مولدات
الكهرباء وتم تجهيز ايضا المكان ليكون
مناسبا لاستقبال المواطنين هنا هنالك
الجزئين من هذه الملاجئ هنالك ملاجئ مؤقته
للاقامه المؤقته في حال انقطع التيار
الكهربائي في المدينه يمكن للمواطن ان
يذهب الى هذا المرجع هناك يمكن ان ينعم
بالدف الذي يفقده في منزله كذلك ان يقوم
بشحن الهواتف السياره او المصابيح وما الى
ذلك نوع اخر هو في حاله الاطفاء
هذه للاقامه الطويله حيث يمكن المواطن ان
ان يكون في هذا الملجا لفترات طويله حتى
هذه اللحظه تم تجهيز
3,360 في جميع المدن الاوكرانيه كانوا
مستخدم 300 و 200 لكن
3200 عفوا
عندما عندما تزور هذه الاماكن وهذه الخيم
وهذه الملاجئ الى اي مدى يبدو تبدو لك هذه
الحلول ناجعه همم وهل هذا يعني ان ازمه
الطاقه والكهرباء ستطول وستمر طويلا لذلك
تلجا السلطات في كياب الى هذه الحلول
او للطالب لابد ان اشير الى ان هنالك
ازدحام كبير جدا في هذه المناجم من قبل
المواطنين لان القطوعات تحدث في جميع
اكثر من 24 ساعه كانت الكهرباء مقطوعه
لذلك المواطنين يذهبون اليها طلبا للدفء
وايضا ل شحن الهواتف السياره
هنالك يكون صفط طويل في الخارج ينتظر ان
يخرج من يخرج من هناك ثم بعد ذلك ليحل له
همم الحل هو ليس يعني لا يمكن لا هو حل
غير عملي لا يمكن ان يكون حل مستدام ولكن
له مؤقتا غلط اولا همم عمليه التواصل
المواطنين يقومون بشحن الهواتف من وجدتهم
يعملون هنالك من يعمل همم عن طريق اون
لاين او عن طريق في وضع غير همم الاتصال
لذلك وجدت البعض يعملون داخل هذه المراكز
همم يباشرون اعماله ووجدت بعض الاخر من
الطلاب الذين يدرسون حتى في هذه الملاهي
هو كثير من الذين ياتون خاص كبار السن
الذين فق الكهرباء والتدفئه والغاز في
منازلهم ايضا هنالك بعض المراكز التي توزع
لتجهيز الطعام للمواطنين وتقديمه بشكل
مجاني هذه الحلول لا يمكن ان تكون حلول
همم يعني طويله ال ال العجل او مستمر
ولكنها تفي بالغرض في الوقت الحالي سميت
طبعا بي لن نكسر يعني هذا الاسم الذي
اطلقته اطلق على المبادره وليها موقع
الكتروني يمكن المواطنين ان يدخل ليعرفوا
اقرب نقطه من طيب همم
وعاطفيا همم حذيفه شكرا جزيلا لك على كل
هذه المتابعه انتقل اعزائي المشاهدين الى
الحدود البيلاروسيا الاوكرانيه ينضم الي
من هناك مفرد العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد
الطقس بالطبع عاصف ومثلج همم عبد الجواد
اهلا وسهلا بك كيف هي الصوره من عندك وهل
الامور تنبؤ بالاسوا كما تقول بعض المواقع
على هذه المنطقه الحدوديه الاوكرانيه ال-
البلا الروسيه ام لا يجب تضخيم الامور ما
زالت هادئه وهادئه جدا
مرحبا طالب نعب بالفعل توتر كبير وحاله من
الغليان على الشريط الحدودي الفاصل بين
بيلاروسيا واوكرانيا ساضع صوره تتحرك طالب
وطري البشهد هنا نحن الان مع كاميرا
العربيه نقف على نقطه حدوديه طبعا ليست هي
ببعيده كثيرا عن الحدود البولنديه وهذه
النقطه التي نشاهدها في الكاميرا الان هي
نقطه الحدود الواصله للاراضي الاوكرانيه
كنا نحاول الاقتراب من هناك ولدينا
التصريح الكامل لكن للاسف طالب طبعا
الاتصالات لا تعمل ونحن مضطرون للوقوف في
هذه النقطه طالب طبعا الوضع على الحدود هو
اشبع بالقنبله الموقوطه طبعا هي تكتك على
شفاء الانفجار طبعا اسلاك شائكه لم يعني
كما اعتدنا على الحدود طالب كانت اسلام
شائكه ورموز طبعا تحدد حدود الدوله لكن
الوضع اليوم هو اكبر من ذلك طبعا هناك
تعزيزات لقوات حرس الحدود البيلاروسيين
كما شاهدنا يقابلها تواجد عسكري اوكراني
مدجج بالمعدات الثقيله في ظل الظروف
الحاليه كما نشاهد تقوم ميسكو وهي حليفه
موسكو برصد التغييرات المتقلبه حاله
استنفار طبعا وحضور سريع للرد في حال حدوث
اي مشاكل كبيره طبعا خاصه انها قامت بدعوه
يعني ال- همم يعني همم عناصر حرس الحدود
الاحتياطيين وجاءت وعادت بهم الى تلك
المنطقه طالب طبعا كما نلاحظ في تلك
المنطقه تقوم الجانب الاوكراني بوضع خط
فاصل حدودي من الاسمنت ومن الاسلاك الشركه
يعيده للاذهان بعض الشيء طبعا همم قضيه
جدار برلين الذي انقذ قسم العالم الى
نصفين في تلك الوقت وانتهى بالدم على ما
يبدو طالب الاستفزازات كبيره خاصه من قبل
الجانبين او من خلال
ولكن عندما تجول في المناطقيه عندما تجول
على المناطق الحدوديه المحاديه هل هنالك
حشود عسكريه اسلحه ثقيله ام لا يعني
والسؤال هل تتحضر بيلاروسيا فعليه لدخول
هذه الحرب يعني في قرار بدخول الحرب املا
لا يجب ايضا تضخيم همم الامور وكل ما يطلق
من تصريحات من قبل ما نسكافيه فقط للتحذير
فقط
طالب يعني حالو هذه النقطه الحدوديه التي
اقف عليها يشبه حال باقي النقاط يعني
والتصريح الذي حصلنا عليه على ما يبدو
يصلنا للنقطه الابسط من حيث وجود التواجد
العسكري ما شاهدناكم وما شاهدناه هناك هو
تواجد مكثف للقوات البيلاروسيه في هذا
المكان طبعا قوات حفظ السلام وقوات مراقبه
كل ما يحدث باعتبار ان طائرات مسيره تظهر
في الجو يتم اسقاط البعض منها هناك بعض
الكاميرات تقوم بالتصوير على مدار الاربع
والعشرين ساعه شاهدنا طبعا مدرعه واحده
فقط على الجانب الاوكراني طالب هي مدرعه
واحده فقط لكن الشريط الحدودي كما يبدو
يعني هو مقدم على مرحله التصعيد كبيره
طالب في حال انفجرت هذه القنبله سيتحول
هذا الشريط الى الشريط بين روسيا
واوكرانيا طبعا
سقوط لقذائف والصواريخ كما هو متوقع في
على هذه الجبهه لكن حتى هذه الوضع كما
تلاحظ ان الان اقف في هذا المكان لا وجود
لاي شخص ولي اي سياره في هذا المكان تعمل
الكاميرات على مدار الساعه والطريق مغلق
بين البلدين على جميع السكان قال من
الحدود البلاريوسيه الاوكرانيه مفرد
العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد شكرا جزيلا لك
جواد على هذه المتابعه